[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday
the 19th anniversary of these september
11th terror attacks that claimed nearly
3 000 lives
was observed on friday due to the
pandemic the annual remembrance at the
september 11th memorial plaza here in
new york included a recorded ceremony
though a separate live event was held
nearby a shortened ceremony was held at
the flight 93 memorial in pennsylvania
while the victims families continue to
seek closure
one important chapter has yet to play
out nearly two decades after the attacks
the men accused of plotting them have
yet to face trial
catherine herridge reports this is peter
his first time holding the baby eunice
hanson
and her husband lee never recovered
after losing their son
peter and his young family it's like
your heart
was crushed by a rock on september 11
2001
peter his wife sue kim and their
daughter christine
were headed to california to visit
family and disneyland
but at 8 52 a.m the hansons got an
alarming call
it was just six minutes after a jet
crashed into the world trade center's
north tower
peter said dad
the plane has been hijacked
and i don't know what they're going to
do where we're going to go
the young family was on united airlines
flight 175.
at 9 am peter made one last call to his
father
he said dad it's going to be quick
don't worry and then he
quietly said oh my god
oh my god three minutes later their
plane slammed into the world trade
center's south tower
we saw it all on television at the same
time that was the horror of it
was your husband ever the same after
the phone call no he was never the same
christine hansen was the youngest of
eight children killed in the attack
her peter rabbit and other keepsakes are
in the 911 museum
she'd be 21 today graduating from
college i have one more year
you lost a lot on that day on 9 11.
i lost most of my family i had lost my
husband at that day too
christine lee hansen 19 years later
eunice hansen is one of many still
waiting for the five suspects
including the self-described architect
of the attack
khalid sheikh mohammed to be prosecuted
at the guantanamo bay cuba
military base what explains the delay of
19 years
that's inexplicable to me defense
attorney edward mcmahon jr
represented 9 11 al-qaeda suspect walnut
benitash
at the military court with all due
respect to the military
they have no ability to put on a very
complicated
death penalty case involving multiple
defendants they've never done it
before the suspects arrived to
guantanamo in 2006
the bush administration held them in
c.i.a secret prisons
where they were interrogated using
extreme tactics
that critics call torture i've always
believed that the very reason
that these defendants were taken to
guantanamo
in the first place was because the c.i.a
wanted to protect these secrets at all
costs
the department of justice will pursue
prosecution
in federal court the obama
administration's
2009 effort to transfer the 911 suspects
to new york city to stand trial failed
after mounting political pressure
and security concerns he wants to give
him
a stage in that federal courthouse
in 2017 lee hansen shared his story with
military investigators
he said all i wanted to do
was get the story out that's all i
wanted
and i want to see justice but he died
the following year
did lee expect to see justice in his
lifetime
he hoped to see justice but he thought
he thought out along he never would a
military spokesman told cbs
news the 9 11 case is complex
and the goal is to afford fairness due
to covet 19
the trial's january start date is
unlikely
eunice often visits the connecticut
cemetery where her husband lee's ashes
were interred with peter sue kim and
christine
i've accepted the fact that my family
has gone home to god
and that gives me peace but i don't
think
i will have peace total peace
myself until the trial
for cbs this morning saturday katherine
herridge
washington fairness is always what we
want
but 19 years later listen to these
families how does your heart not go
out to them it is just unbelievable to
think that this much time has gone by
and to look at the emotional toll that
it has taken
and the physical toll that it has taken
on the hanson family just
it's a tragic family yeah exactly
exactly
one family